et vos frères ils habitent là-bas aussi
j'ai pas de frère oui tout à fait on
habite là-bas si on est bon on va les
garder longtemps on va les garder
longtemps parce qu'on les aime et
franchement c'est un des énormes cartons
de ces quatre dernières années
je suis fier de vous et je vous aime
très fort les frais au voilà je voulais
vous dire on se rappelle ensemble c'est
vrai qu'on s'était rencontrés il ya
quatre ans que je t'ai déjà fan devant
déjà c'est pour ce match qui joue qui
fait déjà je viens de dire à ceux qui ne
savent pas que ça c'est une longue
histoire nous nous trompons pas c'est
vrai un truc qui a paru depuis qu'on est
connue je me souviens venus depuis le
début la première fois que tu m'a appelé
au téléphone c'est hyper stressée et à
chaque fois maintenant quand tu
m'appelles au téléphone j'ai toujours
hyper stressée ou non mais ça n'est pas
rien mais en fait c'est moi qui vous
appelle parce que j'étais fan de ce que
vous faisiez de ya 4 5 ans et je vous
dis j'aurais bien concevoir et tu nous
inviter à manger des frites
ouais c'est vrai nous a offert j'ai mon
père devait déjà faire des sandwichs à
leon dai et c'est vrai oui allez on
dégage c'est des jeunes là c'est bon là
c'est bon quoi sur une carte jeans c'est
bon t'as vraiment bien vu notre
évolution et c'est fou à l'époque en
tant qu on faisait des petites salles
2000 et là on va faire la défense arena
30000 personnes sans skis ça prendra
juste vis bien ils sont avec nous
pictures liste des cinq fort et ça
réagit beaucoup sur le ils en pensent
quoi ton frère vous savez cette séquence
où on voit passer les gens essaient de
se grimer en bd avec hot dogs et et de
se mettre dans la même tenue et on a une
deuxième partie alors oui il ya beaucoup
de potes quand je leur ai dit que je
faisais ça ils m'ont demandé comment ça
se passe tous et pas du tout truck n ya
vraiment un camion c'est ça et on doit
s'habiller très très vite et tout c'est
sur une place de toulouse hyper connue
mais c'est ça et en fait nous on est
tranquillement dans le camion après on
nous dira on a quelqu'un et luba on sort
du cadre
ça donne ça c'est la deuxième partie
sportive
[Musique]
vous pensez quoi de l'arrivée des
trottinettes à toulouse mais j'aime pas
parce que après les jeunes n'avaient pas
conduit les à trottinette est aussi ça
ça fait 1 contre les pollutions pour
l'électricité
je viens de séville espagne en utilise
beaucoup le vélo mais dans le
centre-ville là trottinent essaie
maintenant de nouveau aussi comme dans
l'eure et
ça et vos soeurs ils en pensent quoi
encore vos soeurs elles en pensent quoi
en faire la malle ashton
et voilà mais oui on est et las ketchup
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
pollution à toulouse
écoutez je pense pas que tout soit aussi
peuplé que aussi pollué que ça
maintenant il faut demander tout ce qui
habite toute l'année ici
moi je viens ici pour mon plaisir une
fois par semaine à peu près vous habitez
ou à la base j'habite dans un petit
village du lot qui s'appelle montcuq et
vos frères les habitent là-bas aussi
j'ai pas de frère oui tout à fait on
habite la bastille on est conclu on a
grandi à montcuq coiffé ou je tiens à
dire à tous les gens qui s'amusent à
dire mon cul que c'est pas très drôle
c'est montcuq mexique
tout le monde est bienvenu à montcuq
montcuq monkey pas excusé what is your
opinion à base de pollution in toulouse
[Musique]
sister's sister sister
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on est des roses mais aussi nick fry et
michel je peux parler d'un truc bien sûr
pas si tu peux tout dire parce qu'il ya
eu un buzz comme on dit les qu'en disent
les jeunes à ses vrais ceux qui l'ont
rejointe dirait qu un gros buzz cette
semaine parce que iad j'ai rien compris
hunt a rien compris et il faut qu'on en
parle alors pas faire comme s'il va
raconter l'histoire de